Sterling you said when we asked what
you've done for work at you said it you
started off being a male companion okay
so walk us through that meaning women
we're paying you to kind of be the man
in their life yeah it's actually really
really high earning women that's what I
assumed like a multi-millionaires of
course paying me so what was your
experience with very uh wealthy women
paying you to be a companion and then go
deeper there meaning are they even
attractive would you actually hit it if
they weren't paying you like walk us
through that I don't know if there's
anybody I don't know anybody that's
getting paid by women to do anything
like that so what your story is is very
unique so I'd love to hear it yeah what
you found is that
a lot of these women are very very
lonely so imagine okay women in their
mid 30s generally earning you know
multiple six figures and up mid-30s yeah
yeah so I went directly to like woman
who's 60 years old I don't know why I
did that no mid 30s mid-30s yep okay and
should you guys also go older women or
where'd you go mentally when you said he
was a companion I knew he was going to
say that because really I thought
mid-30s yeah I love that yeah yeah
because you're still at the point where
you desire it physically yeah but you
know did you also think that Natalia
when he said male companion what age did
you think
um I would say like late 30s okay got it
I went way older I went like Sugar Sugar
Mama kind of I think that makes sense go
on Sir go on they would go a little bit
higher yeah but the after the average
was like mid-30s and because they
they've got they get into a point right
they're typically like career woman or
entrepreneurial woman and they're
getting to a point where the kind of guy
they want to be in a relationship with
the kind of the kind of guy that they
want to take them out on a date he ain't
interested in them of course that's
their that's basically their peer and do
they know do they do they understand why
he's not interested do they elaborate on
that no I don't think they do they don't
but they they understand that they can't
get him and so I'm there to fill in that
is it because of their age is it because
of their looks is it because of the
concept of hypergamy that like if you're
making a quarter million dollars or a
half a million dollars a year as a woman
you're only going to mess with a guy
that makes equal to you or more than you
and the dating pool strings all right I
mean only 10 of America makes more than
150 Grand she wants a guy that's on her
level but that guy that's on her level
doesn't want her and the guy that's on
her level that's saying is making a half
a million dollars a year yeah he doesn't
care about your money he just wants a
young hot girl exactly there you go yep
he's going he's going for like the 18 19
year old secretary or whatever yeah and
that leaves her option like because she
ain't willing to go down yes she's not
uh go down financially right so she's
like
right so she's like okay well they still
have this this craving this urge this
desire this need for that companionship
and that love they want to feel
beautiful again of course they want to
feel like they did when they were 20.
yeah and so I come in I fulfill that
role I'm that guy that they're
fantasizing about yeah right wow and she
understands that it's a transactionary
thing yes but she suspends she's able to
suspend that disbelief for an evening so
she can indulge in that fantasy is it
usually just an evening is it longer
than that is it is it a full-on
relationship at some point yeah it could
be it could be a weekend away at a
skiing trip I've had that happen before
you know they've taken me to New Zealand
and we've gone a skiing trip together
for a whole weekend or it'll it'll be a
kind of a relationship over several
several times they'd say you're in
Louisiana
always expect sex
uh it's kind of implied but it's not
really the like 90 of the interaction is
not about the sex really what is it it's
mostly like whining and dining them at
dinner having conversation asking them
questions uh being genuinely curious
being present about them being present
right they pay the bill
yeah they paid the bill yeah so when
dinner comes so we could stay here all
day long Bill comes I'm very clear the
gentlemen out there like listen anything
to do with going out dinner drinks you
have to pay the bill I agree okay I
agree okay unless
you're in a circumstance like this a
very unique circumstance does that ever
break the fantasy does that ever kind of
like not really or do they know before
they even get that like I know they know
beforehand okay okay and one of the big
things I kind of picked up on because I
was doing this when I was like 25 until
I was like 29. wow that was kind of my
age Gap when I was doing it and what I
really clocked on to really quickly was
that I had to be
super aware of not overreacting to the
price of things on the menu like I'm
like I'll ask you in your mid-20s when
you didn't have a lot of money you're
saying yeah bingo so I got it I didn't
have the money I have now
and so like I'm looking at like oh it's
like caviar or this bottle of wine or
whatever I'm sitting like God damn right
right but I'm gonna play it cool yeah
and not react that way when the bill
cobs are when we're ordering things I do
this all the time yeah you got to be
James Bond in there like a really great
example when I went on this this skiing
trip with this uh Chinese millionaire we
will walk around the town or whatever
she went to this jewelry store and she
bought this pair of uh earrings and the
pair of earrings cost like twice as much
as she'd paid me for the entire weekend
wow and I I had to play that off I'm
like in my head I'm thinking
and how do you negotiate the rate with
these women I mean we in Australia this
sort of thing's legal uh or
decriminalize I should say so we have
like forums where we can advertise our
rates and our services and things wow
and you it for like longer trips you
should have negotiated price of the with
the with the client so if you like that
clip click right here to watch another
or if you want to watch the entire size
cast click right here
foreign
[Music]